[Music]
I missed mouth full and the white wings
blow the lone wolf dies at the paxil oh
[Music]
hey everybody a whole bunch of Comic Con
news dropped today so let's break it
down all the stuff they're bringing the
footage they'll show off because it'll
be during the middle of season seven if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything make sure
you click that Bell to enable alerts so
you don't miss any of the videos there's
giveaway stuff happening at the end of
the video too so big Comic Con news is
they just announced their panel I was
actually planning on doing a Gendry
video so I'll still be doing that but
this is just as cool because the thing
that's happening this year is they
announced the people they're bringing
but because it's happening during the
show's run like literally you'll have
Game of Thrones panel on Friday night
during Comic Con then that next Sunday
in the 23rd will get episode 2 so
because they typically bring footage
depending on what part of the cycle of
production they're in they showed off
cast previews in the past when they were
bringing on new big characters like
Duran Martel may he rest in peace
really really exactly Frank Diane Martel
you don't know your own people
they're disgust for you we must and
great and murdered and you did nothing
over in West End butchered and you did
nothing
we're not astonishment you're not sour
cream then they showed off the season 7
production preview because they hadn't
started production yet this year they
can actually show off genuine footage
from advanced episodes so if they don't
screen an episode outright they'll have
footage to show off from later in the
season but once we're in the season
they've released the typical trailers
for advanced episodes so there'll be all
kinds of footage dropping during that
week so it is going to be weird this
year but the people they're actually
bringing to the panel are Theon Greyjoy
grey worm Samwell Brienne sir Davos miss
sandy bran Stark Varys in salsa they
also announced that there's a special
guest from Westeros moderating the panel
like it's supposed to be a celebrity
guest appearance so
it's not an actor from the show I'm
guessing that it's George are Martin and
they pulled some crazy magic to pull
them away from winds of winter so like
the promo said the panel is going to be
1:30 p.m. Friday in Hall H if you're not
in there I'm totally going to do a video
for whatever it is they do and that's in
addition to all the normal videos I'd be
doing during the week anyway during the
season so they'll be episode videos
trailer videos q and A's bonus videos
there'll be all kinds of Game of Thrones
that week it's really fun when
conventions happen in the middle of a
run for something that I do videos for
it's just a really cool opportunity to
do some fun stuff and they do have like
a special winter is here experience that
you can go do outside of comic-con if
you remember that shut the door promo
that I did a video for there was a bunch
of new footage and behind the scenes
stuff in it wasn't a dull don't see
something we've never thankful
[Applause]
[Music]
it'll be a physical interactive
experience that you can go walk around
in they do something like that every
year like a couple seasons ago they did
the Hall of faces before Aria learned
about the Hall of faces in that season
so there's a whole bunch of HBO stuff
happening they have a Westworld panel
that's also going to be happening on
Saturday that I might do a video for too
but the really cool thing lately is
they've been doing a bunch of interviews
with the cast the producers the crew and
they revealed a whole bunch about what's
happening in this scene here they didn't
say outright but you can connect the
dots so they talked about this big
action set piece where they were blowing
both snow and fire in Daenerys his face
while she was filming on the back of
drogon but they filmed it in a big
Belfast quarry that they flattened out
it had 11,000 square meters of concrete
painted over with camouflage it took
about six months to set up so it
definitely implies that there's this big
action set piece with the army of the
Dead Jon Snow barrack in the rest of his
band here but the fact that they filmed
Daenerys scenes there while they were
blowing snow like they said blowing snow
in her face then it's pretty safe to say
that there's going to be some dragons
versus white Walker action towards the
end of the season now no guess as to
what actual episode this takes place
during it could be episode six
it could be Episode seven but there's a
lot of theories that they actually bring
this box back to the dragon pit so this
scene here is back in King's Landing
there's a lot of theories about who this
could be because the Sun is obscuring
their face it could be the Hound
it could be brawn because a lot of
people are still hoping for cleganebowl
but if they actually do get their hands
on a white Walker and bring it back in
this giant box here for the dragon pit
in Cersei and everyone to see then that
implies that they're structuring the
season the way they have done in the
past or even though you end the season
on a holy crap moment
you typically have your big hardhome or
battle of the bastards episode before
the last episode but a lot of that is
based on the times reporter looking at a
big scene that centered around Daenerys
as character where all this stuff is
happening where she's getting all this
snow and fire blown in her face they
weren't allowed to reveal any big
details about the scene but you can put
two and two together where even though
winter has come there's only a couple
places in West
where you'd have like giant gobs of snow
smacking you in the face that would have
to be north of the wall because it's
snowing south of the wall but it'd be
very light
even if she were really high up in the
atmosphere so let me know in the
comments what do you think is going to
happen with the nearest when she takes
drogon up north I mean it's got to be
some huge save for John Stowe because
they look like they're all going to die
in this scene here but obviously you
have the scene of Jon Snow riding off on
his horse berrak and Thoros are really
huge characters but who I definitely
think are going to die and they also
made it sound like they're killing
torment this season because people were
talking about the Brienne relationship
like Oh wouldn't it be great if they did
something with that in Dan and Dave both
responded with oh you know it's time for
one of them to die and if you have to
pick between torment and Brienne about
who they would kill first it just has to
be torment so everybody speculate on
what's going to happen to torment this
season what's going on with this big
white Walker battle but if you're asking
about new trailers dropping yes there
will be more footage before the season
starts they always have three or four
big trailers we've only gotten to so far
so in the next couple weeks they'll drop
more footage there'll be more promos you
know what I'll do because there's so
much other Comic Con news to get through
and there's Rick and Morty tonight is
I'll post my Gendry video in another day
or two when I get a little bit more time
but leave all your video requests in the
comments below
congratulations to David you're the
latest giveaway winner please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details you
can click here for my Ozora high and
Lightbringer video and you can click
here to rewatch the trailers again thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight